Let’s ask a philosophical question: What
is it that makes up a person’s soul?
Is it their personality, their memories, their
emotions, the history of their good and bad
deeds?
Is it an energy that inhabits a living body,
an active consciousness, or even all of the
above?
Or is the soul just an entirely nebulous and
undefinable concept?
The idea of the soul is almost as old as human
civilization itself, with philosophers from
as far back as Ancient Greece and even before
acknowledging its existence..
Numerous religions from all over the world,
if not all of them, also hold teachings about
the nature of souls, even though they might
vary.
For example, Judaism and some denominations
of Christianity state that only human beings
have an immortal soul that will live on in
Heaven after a person’s death, and the end
of their time on Earth.
Meanwhile, certain Catholic theologians - meaning,
people who study religion - claim that a soul
inhabits all living creatures.
And so, the philosophical and theological
debate goes on, with the general consensus
being that souls are… well, they’re a
little bit of everything.
Every part of someone that makes them who
they are: character, emotions, reasoning,
consciousness, memories, and thoughts all
blended together.
But if we accept that a soul is something
that exists, then is it something that can
be altered?
Is it constant or can it be manipulated?
Could a person’s soul even be removed entirely?
At first glance, SCP-158 appears to be a device
resembling a mechanical arm.
In fact, it’s a lot like the kind of machine
you might expect to find inside a huge factory,
standing as part of an assembly line, welding
and drilling components together day in and
day out.
This particular mechanized arm, however, features
a number of unique and bizarre differences
from any currently used in automated production.
For starters, it has an unusual attachment
at one end, a three-pronged, tridactyl-like
claw.
The arm itself is also designed to be suspended
from the ceiling, ideally hanging upside down
in a room big enough to accommodate it.
There is a long series of winding cables connecting
SCP-158 to a complicated computer console
that is used to control the device, while
the remaining cables are intended to be connected
to a power source.
As for the console, it possesses a visual
display unit and a keyboard like you might
expect it to, and at the bottom there is what
appears to be some form of a dispenser, seemingly
designed to attach to a container of some
kind, measuring three inches wide by seven
inches tall.
The ideal receptacle to fit the attachment
is that of a glass jar or beaker.
This mechanical arm was first uncovered by
the Foundation in late 2007, inside a burned-down
hospital in an unknown location that has been
redacted from the SCP-158 file.
The hospital itself was derelict, abandoned,
and appeared to have been unused for a considerable
period of time, approximately five years but
perhaps more.
Agents working for the Foundation recovered
SCP-158, along with an owner’s manual that
presumably would have contained detailed instructions
describing the device’s function and exactly
how to operate it.
This manual had been badly damaged by the
fire, but the readable portions of it were
later transcribed and copied, and now a single
copy of what was left of the manual is kept
with SCP-158 at all times.
While most instructions detailing the operation
of SCP-158 did survive and were able to be
copied, any chapters that might have explained
who built it or what it actually did were
too badly damaged to read, lost to the fire.
Much like the owner’s manual, all components
of SCP-158 - the arm, the console, and the
cables - have all appeared to sustain some
amount of fire damage, but remain intact and
in full working order.
The damage is only cosmetic, and while it
might take around twenty minutes to boot up,
this fire damage doesn’t affect the machine’s
function.
But the question still remains: what exactly
is the intended purpose of this mechanical
arm?
Well, through a long process of trial and
error, and following the surviving portions
of the manual, the Foundation was able to
get the device working again.
They learned that SCP-158 will only perform
its function when presented with an ordinary
living being.
While human beings, namely members of Class
D personnel, are typically used as test subjects
by the Foundation, this actually applies to
any living creature that has the ability to
display cognition, which is the mental process
of gaining knowledge, in order to perform
cognitive functions like thinking, remembering
and problem-solving.
When a person, or other non-human being, possessing
cognition is presented to SCP-158, the machine
will then go to work, and extract an unknown,
gas-based substance from them.
This substance is then deposited in the jar
or beaker that is fitted to the dispenser
beneath the console.
So, what does it take?
Is it some sort of advanced form of decontamination
device, removing all toxins and impurities
from a body?
Oh, if only that were true.
Sadly, you see, the Foundation didn’t give
SCP-158 the nickname of the “Soul Extractor”
for nothing.
After the machine has performed its function,
the now formerly cognitive organism on the
receiving end will display a complete and
total loss of their higher brain functions.
They won’t be able to speak, form coherent
thoughts, or even remember who they were before
SCP-158 was switched on.
The device will rob them of any and all parts
of themselves, essentially leaving the person
or creature as a hollowed-out shell, a husk
of their previous self, a body without a soul.
Perhaps even crueler though, is that this
extraction process is not fatal, and victims
are left alive afterward.
They no longer possess their capability for
cognitive thought, and will not respond to
any form of external stimuli around them.
There has been some level of brain stem activity
recorded in most cases, and subjects have
been known to exhibit basic reflexes, but
this is the only active movement that they
are now capable of.
As for that substance that test subjects have
removed from their bodies?
Well, it takes the form of gas, as we mentioned
earlier, but it also seems to be comprised
of a mixture of kinetic, electrical, heat,
and light energy.
In fact, each jar of the substance is an infinite
source of these various types of energy, albeit
only capable of a very low rate and output
on average.
The general consensus among Foundation researchers
is that this substance is the physical soul
that has been removed from a subject.
So, do they stay stuck as soulless shells
forever?
Actually, SCP-158 is in fact capable of returning
the extracted substance to a subject that
it performed a removal on.
However, whether a test subject, normally
a member of D Class, receives their soul after
having it extracted is all down to whatever
test is being conducted by the Foundation.
Those that do get given their souls back will
usually regain access to all of their previously
lost cognition and higher brain functions,
but the rate at which they return can vary
depending on the subject.
Replacing the substance from one patient with
that of another can also cause these results
to differ.
And again, that’s if the SCP Foundation
even bothers to replace a test subject’s
soul, instead of just leaving them hollowed
out.
It’s actually pretty terrifying to think
that the Foundation has the freedom and the
capability to do that to somebody, taking
away everything that makes someone a human
being, only to leave their soul in a jar while
their vacant body lives on without thought
or consciousness.
It was due to the unique, anomalous function
of SCP-158 that the device was proposed to
become part of a Foundation research endeavor.
Codenamed the “Olympia Project” and overseen
by its head researcher, Professor Kain Pathos
Crow, who has the head of a golden retriever,
but that’s a story for another day.
The ultimate aim of the project was to use
the anomalous properties of a number of SCPs
to successfully create an artificial human
that would become a potential asset of the
SCP Foundation.
As part of one series of Olympia Project experiments,
Professor Crow gathered a group of D Class
personnel to undergo testing using SCP-158.
Each of these individuals had been interviewed
by Crow himself and were selected based on
personality traits and characteristics that
the Professor liked or thought would be useful
to have in the Foundation’s artificial humanoid.
The group chosen by Professor Crow featured
a mix of male and female test subjects, as
Crow believed “a soul transcends the flesh
it is interred in.”
The main purpose of the experiment was to
try and uncover some of the further functions
of SCP-158, basically pushing the machine
to its limit, trying to learn more information
about the device that would have been contained
in the damaged portions of the owner’s manual.
Professor Crow had pored over the sections
that had survived intact, making sure he knew
every available piece of information on SCP-158
inside and out.
The obscured instructions he was able to decipher
were, according to his notes, “sketchy at
best, and downright unhelpful at worst.”
Crow began his experiments by removing the
first subject’s soul and then trying to
use the device to do literally anything else
with the extracted substance.
Despite trying everything he could think of,
the Professor learned there was little the
Soul Extractor could do with a soul once it
had been removed, other than reverse the process
and return the substance to the body it had
been taken from.
By then repeating this with further D Class
test subjects, Crow was able to learn the
exact input sequence needed to reverse a soul
extraction, whilst before this had only ever
been achieved through blind luck.
By his sixth experiment with SCP-158, Professor
Crow noticed there was a brief period in the
middle of performing its function that the
device would pause as if awaiting further
commands.
Crow theorized that this pause was there for
additional sequences to be inputted via the
machine’s console.
He began removing and re-implanting the same
soul into the following test subject, both
to practice but also experiment with the Soul
Extractor’s controls.
The Professor found it strange that, despite
what he was doing to her, the D Class suffered
little to no side effects to her health, even
though her soul was being continually removed
and replaced.
Then, on experiment number eleven, Crow seemed
to crack that little pause SCP-158 took during
each operation.
A new list of commands appeared on the monitor,
like ‘split’, ‘merge’, ‘remove aspects’,
‘add aspects’, and ‘combine aspects’.
It seemed to the Professor that the device
could be used to not only remove souls but
alter them.
Through his further experiments, Crow learned
that the ‘aspects’ the machine mentioned
were elements of a person’s personality,
such as willpower, understanding, conscience,
creativity, empathy; and the Soul Extractor
could be used to manipulate and rewrite a
person’s entire identity, before placing
it back into their body.
However, this took a considerable amount of
testing, causing Professor Crow to grow more
and more frustrated with the complex workings
of the device.
That was until he eventually realized it wasn’t
SCP-158 that was too complicated for its own
good.
The machine was trying to quantify the unquantifiable,
explain something inexplicable: the very nature
of the human soul.
Professor Crow began using SCP-158 to modify
a composite soul, which he referred to as
Subject Zero.
While working on it, he realized the soul
itself seemed to be aware of its surroundings,
possessing a level of knowledge above that
of most Foundation researchers, including
Crow himself.
Either by fluke or by meddling with SCP-158,
the Professor had created a soul that seemed
to exist on several planes of existence beyond
the physical world that we know.
Subject Zero had become a sentient, disembodied
consciousness, an entity that could see, hear,
feel and think without the need for a physical
form or body to house it.
Zero was proposed to become Professor Crow’s
assistant, given that it displayed respect
and admiration to him for having created it.
Almost like a child looking up to a father
figure.
All it asked in return was to be given a name
other than ‘Subject Zero’.
Crow told the disembodied entity it could
name itself whatever it liked.
The Foundation then planned for the composite
soul, now formerly known as Subject Zero,
to be a component of the Olympia Project’s
artificial humanoid, whenever its creation
was successfully completed.
Don’t you just love a happy ending?
Now go check out “Living Ice Cream Van SCP-1386”
and “SCP-261 - Pan-Dimensional Vending Machine”
for more peculiar anomalous machines from
the SCP Foundation!